as copic 19 restrictions are eased on
the las vegas strip we are inching our
way towards
normalcy and that includes the return of
nightlife brian yeah a lot of good
numbers heading in the right direction
but nightclubs will
look a lot different at least at first
oracle man alive in the strip tonight
with more on what he's hearing from
industry leaders orco
well brian and denise for years a
typical night out for many here on the
las vegas strip
involved partying at nightclubs at the
various properties
but that trend is changing and experts
tell me especially following covet 19
night clubs might never be the same
again
we wanted to do something very different
here lorenzo dumani has something
majestic
in mind for this dirt lot near the las
vegas strip just feet away from the
convention center expansion is where
he's building the majestic
las vegas a non-gaming non-smoking
resort and it'll have a new form of
nightlife
no dj's allowed the majestic
will not have a nightclub instead there
will be live entertainment near the pool
area
dumani tells me tastes are transforming
and coven 19 has sped up that process
i think behaviors are going to change to
more physically safer and
healthier environment do you really
think people anymore want to be crammed
in a room
with two or three thousand twenty
something year olds
for more and more people the answer to
that question is no
even prior to the pandemic according to
data from the lvcva
only two percent of visitors surveyed in
2019
said they had been to a hotel nightclub
that charged a cover fee
that number has been dropping for the
last four years meanwhile
21 percent of visitors said they went to
a freestanding borrower lounge with no
cover
that's up from 2018.
[Music]
so are nightclubs dead you always want
to be careful about
giving something last rites unlv
hospitality expert david schwartz says
over the past 20 years
vegas's nightclub scene has adapted to
many changes
and he expects that'll happen now too
it's a little bit hard to imagine what a
socially distanced dance floor would
look like
but i think they might want to
experiment with different
ways of configuring the rooms and
different kinds of programming just to
see what people do react to in the
post-pandemic
environment first up to bat is the omnia
nightclub at caesars palace which
resumes operations in march
only the terrace area will be open and
safety is a top priority
pakistan group saying it's implementing
touchless menu systems and rigorous
cleaning plans
when things get tougher you've got to
you've got to give a little anthony
curtis with the tourism newsletter las
vegas advisor anticipates long-term
alterations
because of the economic hit nightclubs
took from coronavirus closures
what we've seen in the past i don't
think is ever going to come back you're
not going to see
the dj's making the kind of money they
made you're not going to see them
spending the money
going after these high-priced people
these high-priced effects
dumani recognizes club culture won't
disappear but as he prepares to break
ground on the majestic
las vegas this fall he hopes his luxury
lounges offer
a different option i've always thought
it's something that's kind of
sorely missing from vegas
experts stress despite our evolving
party scene
there will always be a market for the
traditional nightclub
reporting live on the las vegas trip
tonight orco mana 8 news now